so our first subject is boris johnson
has said that the uk power grid should
be a hundred percent green by 2035. so
is that an achievable target at tessacon
to you first of all do you welcome this
target and is it doable
yeah anna i mean in short it is doable
and it's most certainly the kind of
ambition that we desperately need to see
from this government um but we can set
targets like this until the cows come
home the really important question is
whether or not this government puts into
place the investments and the policies
that are needed to massively scale up
our zero carbon energy sources and just
as importantly to break the lock that
fossil fuels currently have on our power
supply
and that requires the government to do
two things it requires it to stop giving
massive subsidies to oil and gas
producers in the uk so we know that in
the last five years since the uk
government signed the paris agreement on
climate change it's handed out four
billion pounds in public money to oil
and gas producers in the uk
and the other thing it needs to do is
it's got to say no
to the opening of new oil and gas fields
like the cambo oil field which it's
currently astonishingly considering
giving approval to which will lock us
into reliance on fossil fuels for
decades to come okay let me get james's
reaction and james just before you do
come back i just want to show a
statistic from last year from 2020
43 of britain's electricity was
generated by renewables so there's a way
to go i did notice you laughing at one
point uh during what um tesla was saying
there so so why was that what's your
reaction
well i'm very suspicious of the doctrine
that we're really uh subsidizing fossil
fuels but i'll bow to test her on that
but she must admit that uh we are
subsidizing renewables or intermittent
sources of energy supply which deliver
43 of our power one day and then two
percent another day we're subsidizing
them a whole lot more now if we're
looking at positive solutions it's
pretty obvious that uh boris has had a
hidden conversion to nuclear power
i'm in in favor of that but we must
recognize that uh conservative
governments and the coalition before
them have completely dithered on nuclear
power they've dallied with the
chinese communist party they've drawn up
ridiculous contracts in the case of
hinckley point they've angered hitachi
so the japanese firm
pulled out they've dithered on small
modular reactors
and most of the nuclear fleet will be
retired by april the 1st april fools day
on 2024
so if you want to make the targets
you've got to do a lot of investment in
nuclear such as we're unprepared really
to make the last few years now i believe
they're going to announce two more
nuclear power stations big deal okay uh
tessa what's your take on nuclear some
people say that you need a kind of
dependable source of energy for when the
sun doesn't shine or the wind doesn't
blow what's your take on it
well anna there are a number of
different scenarios for how we can get
to that zero carbon electricity grid by
2035. and the challenge is that if we
want to keep costs down which is a huge
concern obviously especially in light of
the gas price crisis i mean new nuclear
power plants cost tens of billions of
pounds as size well c will cost and it
will take another 12 years to build so
that doesn't seem like a great solution
given the other solutions that are ready
to scale that are desperately
underfunded at the moment and cost is
important isn't it james because people
are worried about higher bills for
starters but also people are worried
about a transition away from jobs they
might have people in the fossil fuel
industry are concerned about losing
those jobs
well completely right and they're right
to be concerned i think what we've got
we've got to be very uh crystal clear
here uh um anna which is really when
boris says you know oh i'm so worried
about gas prices in the same breath he's
saying he's going to protect consumers
by making gas more heavily taxed so that
they shift in a nudge-like fashion to
electricity this
ladies and gentlemen it's the class war
by another means it will mean more
expensive uh gas cooking and heating for
those who retain the old supply uh they
will be put in a difficult position if
he's ridiculous targets uh ever come to
fruition they certainly won't by 2035.
you know the the whole opinion in the
environmental things is people need to
lay out more money to be better people
uh for the right kind of clean so clean
pure energy okay and i don't buy it